dans les starting blocks un robot made
in france l'un des fleurons de l'équipe
numéro 2 enfin ce sera bientôt le cas
emma et sa coéquipière italienne apporte
les derniers ajustements chaque engin à
sa botte secrète
oui c'est ce qui permet de elle roule
pas en fait elles sont justes et ça
permet de les dire âge soit plus facile
en fait ce qui a été toujours quand même
pour moi c'était la programmation ce que
je savais pas du tout en servir comme il
fallait mettre pour les variables tout
ça un projet erasmus entièrement financé
par l'europe pendant un an 48 élèves de
niveau secondaire plancher sur un
prototype capable de traverser ce
labyrinthe
ils sont espagnols italiens et français
des équipes transnationales langue
anglaise obligatoires c'est primordial
pour le marché du travail surtout dans
les sciences et la technologie parce
qu'on utilise l'anglais tout
particulièrement
et puis pour communiquer de façon
générale et découvrir ds
l'idée suscité l envie d'innover ou
simplement le goût des sciences de
l'ingénieur l'école des arts et métiers
à cluny avait tout intérêt à prendre
part au projet conquérir les filles à
peine 20% des effectifs actuellement on
trouve toujours des filles dans les
sciences les sciences oui les sciences
du vivant oui les mathématiques oui les
sciences un peu plus rectiligne un peu
plus géométriques que moins donc on en a
besoin aussi pour enrichir nos
comportements de façon de réfléchir
eurobot izon ensemble c'est son nom
accueillera une nouvelle promotion
l'année prochaine le projet est financé
jusqu'en 2019
[Applaudissements]